scientists have recorded the sound of
two black holes colliding billions of
years ago the signal was picked up by
giant highly sensitive antenna located
in Washington State and Louisiana
perhaps the biggest scientific
breakthrough since the discovery of the
Higgs particle it shows that huge burst
of energy in the universe can alter the
flow of time here we explain this
extraordinary discovery in a little more
detail scientists say they detected for
the first time ever signs of
gravitational waves a byproduct of
seismic events in the universe like the
collision of two black holes or a major
star explosion moving at the speed of
light these waves ripple out across the
universe warping and melding space as
they go this discovery comes after
decades of searching and confirms a
final prediction from Albert Einstein's
theory of general relativity something
the physicist put forward about a
hundred years ago researchers say the
discovery will help us to fully
understand gravity and even learn more
about what happened in the Big Bang if
Albert Einstein were here today I'm sure
he'd be delighted to see science finally
prove his theory right